six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's go to our next caller
from the 505 area code caller from 505
go ahead
hey David this is John from New Mexico
hey I just had a question if you could
have any conspiracy theory or
quote-unquote conspiracy theory it
completely revealed and just out there
so it's no longer in question and some
examples would be something like 9/11 or
climate change or just the the
corruption of politics you know money in
politics or the variables or
investigation let me see if I understand
what was that let me see if I understand
you're saying if I could pick a
conspiracy theory and have it ravit have
it be true which one would it be not
necessarily be true but just look have
it out there so it's no longer
conspiracy because for example some you
know Republicans think that climate
change is a hey oh I see yeah you see
what I mean so you're saying like some
people think 9/11 was an inside job it
wouldn't be that do I want 9/11 to be
proven as true but just if we could
definitively prove that 9/11 wasn't an
inside job like would that be the one
that I would write I think it would be
climate change because right now it's
having the moat it's going to have the
most long-term impact on us I think that
that would be that would be it right in
a thousand years I don't know how much
it will matter whether it was ultimately
debunked that 9/11 was an inside job
that it was the Israeli Mossad working
in concert with the you know Dick Cheney
and Bush and whatever else but if we
continue to have people believe that the
entire climate change reality is just a
hoax then I think that would that would
be hugely damaging in a thousand years I
just hesitate to say that climate change
is a conspiracy theory in other words
there's fringe elements that deny it but
by and large I just don't know that that
it's even a conspiracy theory at this
point you know
sure sure I didn't know if I was the
right level to put to it but just in the
sense that some people or a vast amount
of you know us Americans we yeah we're
not me but we tend to think that oh it's
a Chinese hoax or whatever whatever so
yeah
your answer man do you have one in
particular in mind I was I was thinking
climate change as well just because that
is the most beneficial and if we could
just kind of move past this rut that
we're in and start going towards you
know a more eco-friendly approach to our
lifestyles I think that would be
probably the best thing to do yeah I
guess a better way to say it instead of
conspiracy is what is there where if we
could get the world completely united in
terms of what we believe is going on
would do the most good and that's where
like listen in the end if people think
Paul McCartney died 40 years ago and was
replaced with a similar-looking
left-handed bassist it's not really
gonna make that big of a difference
whether we get agreement on that or not
even if the moon landing was faked
right like but the climate change one if
we could just get a hundred percent
agreement that this is what's going on I
think it would do the most good
long-term for us absolutely man well I
appreciate you taking my call thank you
appreciate the call